towards the end of the book you you've
got a whole section called um on a
meaningful life people have been trying
to answer this question for like
millennia so what what's the kind of
psychology recent scientific take on
what how how do we live a meaningful
life sure so a lot of the stuff from
that section is taken from i really like
using um acceptance and commitment
therapy act um which has a whole
um
sort of part of that therapy is around
understanding your own values and what
gives you meaning and purpose in life
um
and
yeah so i've devoted a whole section to
it because i think it's so so important
and i also think it's important to
not just do it once but to keep doing
sort of little values check-ins where
you
you just step back get a bit of a
bird's-eye view on what's going on in
your life at this point what matters
most to you at this point because it
changes right you know what was
important to you at 21 might not be the
same things that are important to you at
31. so your values change as you go
along but
the way um that we set it out in therapy
is is that
a value is like
a path that you follow your whole life
there is no end to it but you just you
value that part so you want to stay
close to it as much as you can so a goal
is something you
once you've done it you you've done it
it's finished so your your goal might be
to do a marathon but your value might be
to stay fit and healthy
and so the marathon becomes one of many
possible goals along the way
but your value is to
to continue to be fit and healthy along
the way
so that's the path yeah it's fitting how
you know fitness and health yeah um and
then there can be lots of her lots of
hurdles and lots of goals along the way
um
but at times life steers you away from
those so you know you might life happens
and maybe your job is very intense or
you have children or whatever it is and
it might stay away from that path and so
that's why i think it's so important to
do these regular
sort of values check-ins where you go
oh i'm not feeling quite right and
actually lots of people come to therapy
with that sort of sense of i'm not
really sure what the problem is i just
i'm feeling a bit lost or a bit you know
life feels a bit meaningless at the
moment and often that's because people
have lost touch with what's most
important to them or life has steered
them away from things that matter to
them
and so just getting clarity on what does
matter to me what is the most important
thing or things in my life at the moment
and what kind of person do i want to be
in those areas of my life
um
which then allows you to set goals
based on the life that you want to have
or the person that you want to be how
how do you go about figuring out your
values
so there are lots of kind of little
exercises you do you can do
sometimes you can literally just grab a
piece of paper um separate into little
boxes and you might have boxes for
family life or
lifelong learning or
health or creativity so you can kind of
fill those boxes with the different
aspects of your life and then in each
box kind of ask yourself
what kind of person do i want to be in
this area of my life so
maybe it's family relationships
what kind of son do i want to be to my
mum what kind of my dad and you know
what kind of relationship do i want to
have
what do i want to represent to those
people
how would that show up in terms of
behavior and action you know daily
behavior um and you just kind of fill it
with with words or bullet points and
that gives you this this
picture of what life would be like if
you were living in line with all of
those values and sometimes they pull on
each other so sometimes they conflict
you know you might have this um real
idea of being a
um
you know successful entrepreneur but
actually that sucks all of your time and
you also want to be a family guy and you
want to spend time with your kids or you
know and so often there's this idea you
know this sort of this balancing act
where okay life has pulled me in one
direction and i want to pull it back
this way so it's not about
setting goals and doing them perfectly
it's about always just tipping the
balance um you know i haven't been
working out for a while because i've
been so focused on work so i know i'm
just going to come back in this
direction a little bit more and and
balance things out um so it's really
just getting clarity
but it's also not not focusing on um
what happens to you so it's not saying
this is what i want in my life because
then things can happen and then you
think failed it hasn't worked out it's
really not it's really not about what
happens to you it's about
how you want to be
in the face of all the stuff that life
throws at us how do i want to respond
when hard stuff happens how do i want to
respond when i'm in a good place
and stuff like that hey friends thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day